could Alex curtzman be about to sell
secret hideout to Paramount and jump
ship welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
and moveie
[Music]
channel so Paramount has some money
issues we've talked about this in
several videos before they have 15 or 16
billion dollars worth of debt debt that
needs to be restructured in the next 12
months and there are lots of business
insiders discussing the possibility that
actually at some point in the next 12
months CBS and Paramount might have to
part ways and that actually Paramount or
at least parts of Paramount might get
sold to a another party that actually it
is the only way for CBS to move forwards
and further to that the first victim of
this potential
breakup would be Paramount plus now
Paramount plus is one of the big reasons
why Paramount has 15 to6 billion dollars
worth of debt they have spent a crapload
of money establishing Paramount plus and
to be honest I think they've done a
bloody good job Paramount plus has
actually very quietly become one of the
main streaming services I watch most
regularly I just watched the Tulsa King
with Sylvester Stallone and it is bloody
brilliant
and if you actually look at a few
projects they've got coming up in the
next 12 months they've got some good
stuff coming Paramount Plus for me is
probably my third favorite of the
streaming services behind apple and
Prime I think I watch it more than I
watch Netflix now which is saying
something but it has been massively
expensive and Paramount may need to cut
its losses so why is this relevant to
Alex Curt's and secret hideout well a
source came to me a few days ago and
actually suggested that they'd been
speaking to somebody over at par that's
very reliable according to them and that
has told them that actually Paramount
are planning to buy secret hideout out
from under Alex kursman and Rebrand it
Star Trek Studios now at that point I
hadn't heard that rumor before but I did
share it with a source that is actually
I know is close to Paramount and close
to the business side of things and then
actually said that that is a possibility
now it is not the foregone conclusion
that the initial Source suggested but it
is a definite possibility that Alex
curtzman would quite like to move away
from Star Trek he has lots of other
projects you can just go and look at his
IMDb that are actually not being
produced via secret hideout so Alex
curtzman may want to leave to go and
work on other things but why would param
want to buy secret hideout why couldn't
secret hideout just sort of go and do
other stuff well Paramount has several
contracts now with secret hideout
regarding Star Trek and any first dibs
basically secret hideout can't do
anything without offering it to
Paramount first that does limit what
Alex kurtzman can then do for example
he's doing now you see me three
currently he cannot do that with secret
hideout he's having to do it separately
for Paramount they would like to do
something a bit different with Star Trek
moving forwards but they can't because
of the contracts with secret hideout so
a possible solution for both parties for
Alex curman that wants to go and do
something else and for Paramount they
want to do something different with Star
Trek is for Alex curtzman to be bought
out of secret hideout for Paramount to
take over the company and for them to
absorb Star Trek Back back into the fold
this way they would be able to do what
they want with Star Trek now instead of
waiting 3 years for the current
contracts to end another big problem
that Paramount has though is that
actually secret hideout own elements of
the Star Trek that they've produced so
for example if Paramount wanted to
continue with strange new worlds they
would have to include currently secret
hideout if secret hideouts contracts
were ended tomorrow Paramount wouldn't
actually be allowed to produce more
strange new worlds as crazy as that
sounds but it's the way the contracts
were set up so again if Paramount wants
to actually do something different with
Star Trek but still keep the bits of the
current Star Trek they like they need to
take over secret hideout there is also
though quite an important business
reason why power might need to do this
before they start looking at selling
elements or the entire business to a
third party Star Trek is one of their
most valuable franchises and currently
Paramount don't own the whole cake
because secret hideout has these
contracts that allows them to own
elements of the IP and actually in some
ways they own the shows they've
made and Paramount are basically just
renting it it means that one of
Paramount's most valuable resources is
less valuable anybody that comes in and
buys it are basically having to buy this
at least threeyear deal with secret
hideout to and then they will not
completely control the Star Trek that is
currently being made so anybody that
actually bought Paramount wouldn't
really own strange new worlds they
wouldn't own lowex they wouldn't own
Prodigy and they wouldn't really own
anything else that secret hideout is
planning so a way of getting around that
clearly Paramount buys secret hideout
REM markets it as Star Trek Studios
where you can still bring in people like
Gan rodeny and rodeny production and you
can still have the whole team there that
is currently producing Star Trek but all
of a sudden Paramount owns one of its
most valuable resources in entirety it
owns the cake it owns the icing it owns
the candles on top and when they are
touting the business for a new owner
that will be a big plus generally
speaking when a business comes in to buy
another business they want it to be as
simple as possible they do not want
complicated contracts with third parties
to have to deal with and I am told that
the contracts that kurtzman has with
Paramount are absolutely Rock Solid and
they don't have many loopholes that
would allow any new owner to get out of
them so if Paramount really is up for
sale in the next 12 months and you don't
have to take my word for it just Google
Paramount up for sale in 2024 and you
will find lots of business insiders that
are suggesting it then actually
Paramount buying out curtzman and
bringing secret hideout into the fold
might not just be a good thing for trees
because we'd get rid of curtzman but
also it might be a very good thing for
Paramount now this is a very boring
video about business but if you're a
treky this is incredibly important
because it really will change the future
of Star Trek now things seem to be going
quite slowly at the moment with Star
Trek we've not had any news from Legacy
even though some of my sources are
saying actually that there is a deal
currently being proposed with Amazon to
part fund to the new Legacy series and
actually that might be announced
anything in the next three to four
months we've not heard a lot about
Starfleet Academy we've we do seem to be
getting the movie of section 31 Michelle
yo but only really because Michelle yo
has pushed for it is that all because
Paramount are stalling because they are
trying to decide financially what they
need to do in the next 12 months and
those financial decisions are going to
massively impact what projects it can
push forwards with and if they sell they
need to buy secret hideout it's just
whether Alex curtzman can be offered a
deal that interests him enough to go for
it I suspect he would but guys what do
you think against the comments would CBS
Paramount buying secret hideout out from
under Alex curtzman be a good thing
pushing the kurtzman out the guy to be
honest that I still feel has caused an
awful lot of problems in the Tre world
over the last few years and really where
there is division within the fan base
it's been caused by him so would that be
a good thing for you or actually do you
like the Star Trek that's been produced
in the last few years and actually would
you prefer secret hideout does keep
involved because even though not all of
the Trek has been brilliant they have
done some really good stuff and they do
seem to be going in the right direction
peard season 3 was great the last season
of lower decks was brilliant the last
season of strange new worlds was okay
but it was still good and would it be a
shame for them to now lose all of that
momentum get into the comments and tell
me what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit the
Bell notification do all those buttony
things also go to patreon.com citre
where most of our new videos appear
first and you get to see them without
the adverts finally go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our story and we try to add a little bit
more detail for you to digest please go
check it out as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next
[Music]
time